Woo. So much courage. So much so much. I
say it almost every week, but it's just
it's so true to come through those doors
and uh when you're, you know, someone
new. So, thank you for being here. Um
before we jump in, I want to mention um
that I will be taking the next few weeks
off. So, I won't be here on Sundays for
the remainder of July. And it's like a
little mini a mini sbatical. And uh we
do that I do that um not because
anything's wrong, but so that nothing
goes wrong.
There's I was actually looking up I
won't share them all with you but I was
looking like just kind of out of
curiosity I googled like um pastoral
burnout rates and I was like oh they're
not good. Um it was something like over
90% at some point 90% of pastors say
like I feel I'm like utterly depleted.
You know burnout is sort of different
than like I'm real tired because real
tired is like let me go let me get I
just need a weekend or maybe a week let
me just have a little vacation and you
recover you know. But burnout is like uh
oh, you know, that's like months
recovery, maybe a year. You know, it's
bad. Um, some of you have been there.
Any school teachers in the house? You
know, probably been there. Oh my gosh.
I'm sure the rates are worse for school
teachers. Um, really a lot of the
helping professions just like um so
anyway, all to say like I it's Yeah,
nothing's wrong, but I just um I don't
want things to go wrong and we and we
value here at the table rest. We really
try. It's a tricky thing is on the one
hand we are a very um I kind of the term
I've been using lately is post
evangelical meaning um we're not exactly
like you know I don't know if the
evangelicals I don't think would have us
but um
there is still we were many of us not
everyone we have folks from Catholic
backgrounds and other you know
backgrounds but um many are kind of have
those roots and so that is kind of a
little bit of the ethos of the church
like we are you know like for example
we're all about like getting involved
you know join a small group you know
serve join a ministry team, you know, I
mean, like that's that's like super
evangelical and but I think it's
beautiful. Like it's a good part of it.
Um the the danger in it though is it can
lead to a little bit of burnout. We like
So we do try to be really careful like
we have rotations on teams and because
boy, you can get fried to a crisp. That
was another stat. 7% of pastors say they
are currently fried to a crisp. That's
the quote. I'm not even making that up.
Uh and this is a funny survey. Would you
say that you're currently fried to a
crisp? Yes, that's what I was, you know,
um I'm imagining that servant. Um so all
that to say, yeah, I won't be here, but
um the church will go on. Someone asked
me when they heard I was going to be out
like, "Wait, is no church?" I was like,
"Oh, no, don't worry. Community,
everything continues, um just without
Pastor Brett." And uh and I'll be back
in August. So, um with that in mind,
this is the the fourth and uh final
message in the series. Next week, we're
going to do a panel discussion, which
I'm very excited about, kind of
reflecting on the series. Um but um the
last message is uh titled in our series
right now is sticks and stones
rethinking the church's stance on sexual
orientation and gender. And uh like Miam
referenced at the beginning of of the
service tonight um this is you know the
Bible's obviously it's been used I think
most of us know um has been used
continues to be used to um to shame to
wound to exclude
um folks and uh in the LGBT community.
And so this this series is really about
kind of asking the question like well
could we go back to the scriptures and
could we read them with new eyes? so to
speak, um to see if Christ can speak a
liberating and a healing and a
lifegiving word since um that's who
Christ was. You know, he did a lot of
speaking liberating, healing,
life-giving words um in his time in the
flesh here. And so, we want to do the
same. So, we've just been kind of going
back like week one, we did kind of all
of the classic clobber passages. Um,
since then we've kind of been different
places, but just always back to the
scriptures, kind of thinking like, okay,
what's the what's the lifegiving word
here um for us? So, that's that's kind
of where we've been. Um, so with that in
mind, the title of my message specific
to tonight is uh you'll some of you will
know this, you'll recognize I'm ripping
someone off. Terrible, horrible, no
good, very bad fruit. Uh, for some of
you know the children's book. Yeah, some
of you know. Um, terrible, horrible, no
good, very bad day, I think it is. I
haven't read it in 30 years, you know,
so I'm not sure. But um but the I'm kind
of drawing this. This is uh a passage
very famous quote um from Jesus. This is
Matthew chapter 7 uh verses 16 through
20 where Jesus asks, "Can you pick
grapes from thorn bushes or figs from
thistles?"
It's a classic rhetorical question
because we all know the answer. Uh, a
good tree produces good fruit and a bad
tree produces bad fruit. A good tree
can't produce bad fruit and a bad tree
can't produce good fruit. So every tree
that does not produce good fruit is
chopped down, thrown into the fire. Yes,
just as you can identify a tree by its
fruit, so you can identify people by
their actions.
So, I was um I must have been my early
20s and I had this little
moment with the the father of my at that
time like one of my best closest
friends. Um and uh I was walking out of
church and I can still kind of envision,
you know, you have these memories you
can like it's like a picture almost you
can see in your mind, you know, and I'm
like walking out of church and my
friend's dad is there. He has his Bible
kind of under his arm, which will become
important later. And uh I don't know if
I had a book with me. Probably not. I
don't think I would have brought that to
church, but I somehow we got on the
topic of reading and what I was reading
recently. Um I mean, those of you who
know with my e letters and stuff, I'm
always reading and I'm always an
evangelist for books. I'm like a book
evangelist. Evangelist for Jesus and for
books. And uh so I had somehow I got on
the top where I was like I was so
excited to share with him the recent
work of Christian theology that I was
reading at that time. That's important.
It was Christian theology. All right. So
I'm very into this and I'm like, you
know, and if you ever want to read it,
you know, just you I'll you can borrow
it, whatever you want. You know, I'm
very passionate evangelist. So I'm like,
yeah, it's yours. And he's like, okay,
well, and he takes out his Bible and he
holds in his hand. says, "Well, Brett,
this is the only book that I read." Then
he patted it like that and I was like,
now in that moment, this was a strange
moment, you know, I didn't quite know
how to respond because on the one hand,
I was like, I get it. Oh, and then he
followed up. I forgot the second part,
which is even better. He said, "Why
would I get man's opinion
when I could get God's?"
You know what I mean? Oh, I heard a
collective s collective moan. Um, okay.
So, what's the trouble with this? I
mean, obviously, it was strange. I
didn't want to just like immediately
push back on her or something. Or
honestly, at that time, I don't think I
even had the theological wherewithal to
be able to I just kind of knew
instinctively my Spidey s my Christian
Spidey senses were saying like, "I don't
know, man. I don't you what's the uh
Lord of the Rings? Your words would
sound like wisdom were it not for the
warning in my heart. Um I just had that
warning you know warning in my heart
now. Why? Because I oppose the Bible and
no I like read it every morning. I've
been reading that thing every morning
for I don't know decades. Um so it
wasn't that you know so later I kind of
developed some language and like
perspective on like okay why did why did
my spidey senses go off? And the reason
um is because of course uh I named this
actually in week one of this series that
you know we don't simply read the Bible
right we're always interpreting um and
it's not like oh you all are
interpreting no no I'm saying that kind
of humbles us all right so it's not
about a power thing of like oh you all
interpret you but then I'm a pastor and
I don't you know no like everyone in
other words like when we come to the
scriptures right there's words and we
ascribe meaning to those, right? And
where do we draw that? This is the
trick, right? Is every sermon that
gentleman had ever heard, every word
uttered that's still rumbling around in
the sub his subconscious from like his
third grade Sunday school teacher, every
song he's heard on the radio, every
political ad he's I mean, every right,
it's all rumbling around in the back.
And we kind of bring all of that like
into our interpretation, right? This is
why um what the way I'd kind of define
what he was doing there is um as
something called biblicism.
And um even though it sounds sort of
like, oh that's good, but I think
actually biblicism isn't super
Christian. Um, biblicism holds fiercely
to scripture while rejecting church
tradition, reason, and experience as
sources of knowing. In other words,
right, it's what he said. Hey, why would
I have any use anything else? I'll just
get I'll just go straight to the source
and get God's perspective. And of
course, that's the the trick. So in
other words, um kind of what I'm naming
is I I think this is a kind of a both
and moment where scripture even I would
weight scripture more than these. Um and
yet I think it's important for example
church tradition that would be like even
a commentary. I think it can be really
wise to go and be like, "So, what have
others said about this?" Both past and
present. That can be wisdom, right?
Like, okay, before I just bring all of
my assumptions, it would be nice to hear
where is they where are they coming
from? What's that? You know, and and as
you get a feel for like what some where
something has been um or kind of how
it's been held, how a scripture has been
interpreted through the years, you'll
probably get a little more accurate. um
or bring in for example science into the
conversation, philosophy, um the arts,
literature, poetry,
um and of course experience, right? Even
just like, okay, so I have an
interpretation and I'm going to live it.
How'd it go?
You know what I mean? Like for example,
we'll just take a totally like different
topic. Something like anger. That's a
that's actually I think a really tricky
nuance thing. You know, like the
scriptures at certain points say like do
not be angry, you You know, so it's
like, oh, so it's like, is it bad to be
angry? Well, you can go ahead and try
that. What happens? You have anger? It
It's there before you even know it. So,
what often happens? People are like,
"Well, I can't be angry. That's
uncchristian." And so, they like stuff
it. You know what I mean? Like, stuff
that anger because the Christians aren't
angry. And can you see where it's like,
"Well, actually, hm, maybe there's like
healthy ways to process that anger.
Maybe that, you know, I mean, and we
kind of nuance it as churches and as
families and traditions, right? we all
kind of process the topic and we start
to kind of find our way on it, you know,
and there's there's wisdom in kind of
drawing from these sources. Now, where I
kind of want to go is um I think this is
also true with um experience
and and often those who hold a kind of a
more biblicist perspective really are
down on the experience side of things.
um like oh you're just well you're going
to just rely on your experience well I'm
relying on God you know and um again
though you can see where that can um
well it can get you into trouble now
there's um the kind of how does this you
know relate to our series and to our
topic um I think most many of you are
probably already connecting the dots but
um just to make it explicit this often
kind of lies at the heart of much
conversation in churches around LGBTQ
folks and church and Christian theology
Um because often um queer Christians are
trying to talk about their experiences
and often that is very quickly just
shut down.
And
that I I that's I think problematic what
it what it can even lead to again not
just around LGBTQ but even just for
Christians in general it can kind of
lead to this massive disconnect between
like me and what I feel and my own
experience and like my faith and the
truth and scripture and right in other
words instead of kind of healthfully
bringing all of these things into
conversation
we we kind of try to separate them and
then we just like squash one. Now, just
to be clear, I'm not suggesting that we
just swing the pendulum and now it's
like all of throw out the scriptures,
throw out Christian theology and anyone
else's thoughts and throw science and
just all that, you know, what I feel
makes it real and what I like makes it
right, you know. Okay, obviously that's
its own disaster. Uh can I get an amen?
like that's very immature and you know
my subjective experience is true for
everyone in the whole world and I'm
going to build whole systems based just
on me you know it's sort of okay um so
I'm not trying to swing in other words
I'm what I'm trying to get at is a
little more modest um I'm just saying
like hey seems like wisdom to like let's
kind of start bringting these in
conversation with one another um the way
um Matthew Vines who wrote God the Gay
Christian um probably one of the more
he's um famous kind kind of gay
Christians out there right now. Um he
has an organization called the
Reformation Project. Go to their
website. He's kind of summarized this
point really well. And here's how he
kind of summed up the perspective like
those you know Christians who um kind of
would maybe you know want to push back
on um LGBTQ affirming folks. He said he
kind of frames it says this is how I
think what they often say. um they would
say LGBTQ affirming Christians elevate
their experience over the authority of
scripture in order to support their
views.
Um right so that's kind of the argument.
It's like hey you can't you can't do
that right scriptures that's supreme and
that's the thing. Um now here's I think
an interesting this is how he responded
to that. Um he says experience of sound
Christian teachings
should what?
Show good fruit
not bad fruit.
Um in other words experience plays a
role here.
How does that interpreted? How does that
play out in our lives?
That matters. Now, who is Matthew Vines
drawing from for this insight?
Jesus said, "Yes, just as you can
identify a tree by its fruit, so you can
identify people by their actions."
And and I would want to and you can see
kind of what Vines is doing. He's
expanding that to say, not only can you
sort of judge like an individual life,
not he's not talking about like a snap
judgement. I just met you. I'm judging
you. You know, not that. But like, you
know, you get to know someone closely
for like five, 10 years, you got a
pretty good read. You know what I mean?
Like, you've seen how they act. You kind
of know the fruit, the the results, the
um yeah, the results of their life,
whether it's like the good, the
beautiful, true things and lovely things
and the other parts of their life,
right? The other fruit. Um and in the
same way you can do that with
individuals,
um you can I think do that with
theologies.
You can do that with the interpretations
of scripture because I think what he's
naming I think is actually a really good
principle that when I interpret the
scriptures rightly, it always leads to
flourishing. It always leads to love. It
always leads to freedom and peace and
joy.
What is known as the fruit of the
spirit, right? the you can see the
metaphor like this is how we know when
God's on the move when we see those
things kind of bubbling up in us and the
people around us and vice versa, right?
When it's sort of like, okay, I thought
I was reading that right, but boy, this
is destroying me.
Yeah, it's time to rethink.
Um, and again, not necessarily just
impulsively or after a week, you know,
but like you get you get 10, 20, 30
years down the road with interpretations
and you start to get a feel for um the
fruit that um is being produced, right?
Are y'all tracking with me? So, so this
kind of begs the question like, well, um
what what is what is the fruit? Um
what's the fruit that a more um
classic Christian understanding um of
these things has has brought about? The
way I might maybe sum it up is I think
the church's traditional theology around
sexual orientation and gender is
producing rotten fruit. Um no good, what
is it? terrible, horrible, no good, very
bad fruit. It's real bad. Um, but what
is some of that bad? Like, what am I
what am I talking about? Let me unpack
this a little bit. This is um the US
government Substance Abuse Mental Health
Services Administration. They did a 2021
2022 survey of over 100,000 gay,
lesbian, bisexual people. And um the
results of this, I mean, it just it just
blew my mind. sexual minorities um
sexual minority males were two to three
times more likely than straight males to
have had an MDE that's a major
depressive episode in the past year. two
to three times more likely.
Actually, as we go through these, you'll
notice over and over and over, um,
bisexual folks, and sorry, this study
just didn't include some of the other
letters of the alphabet, so to speak.
Um, but bisexual folks are almost always
worse off over and over. Um, which I
think comes back to they often find
themselves not totally accepted by any
community. Um, let's continue. Sexual
minority females were two to three times
more likely than straight females to
have used illicit drugs in the past
year. Sexual
minority females were more likely than
straight females to have had an SMI.
That's a serious mental illness in the
past year. A pattern similar to the
findings for the past year of any mental
illness. Bisexual females also were more
likely than lesbian females to have had
a serious mental illness. One in five
bisexual females had a serious mental
illness in the past year. One in five.
20%.
Serious, right? Not any. Not like I've
really been struggling with anxiety. No.
So like a serious mental illness often
leading to like hospitalization kind of
situation.
The prevalence of making a suicide plan
in the past year was five times higher
among bisexual females than among
straight females.
The prevalence among lesbian females was
more than four times higher than among
straight females. Bisexual males and gay
males were more likely than straight
males to have had serious thoughts of
suicide in the past year. About three
times as likely for bisexual males. more
than twice as likely for gay males.
Sorry, I know these stats are like
really heavy, but um I think we really
have to grapple with the the rotten
fruit that's is just there. It's just
there. Um 2022 National Survey of 34,000
LGBTQ youth. This was done by the Trevor
Project. Um and they did a survey. This
was from um 20 Yeah, 22 and it was ages
13 to 24.
This is what they found. Fewer than one
in three transgender and non-binary
youth found their home to be gender
affirming.
Fewer than one in three. Less than 33%.
58% of LGBTQ youth reported experiencing
symptoms of depression.
55% of transgender boys and young men
and 47% of girls and young women have
been physically threatened or harmed due
to their gender identity.
45 Oh my god, this just breaks my heart.
45% of LGBTQ youth seriously considered
suicide in the past year.
45%.
14% of LGBTQ youth attempted suicide in
the past year.
And in fact, if you tighten those
parameters and just look ages 13 to 17,
both of those last two statistics go up
from um was it 48? They go up to 50%
or sorry, 45 up to 50 and then from 14%
attempting to 18% attempting. So it gets
worse the younger that you go.
Now, um I I could imagine, you know,
maybe someone's push back might be like,
well, perhaps this is, you know, the
result of someone choosing like it's
their own fruit, so to speak. They're
not they're not in alignment with God's
will or, you know, something like that.
Um, and I want to respond to that even
though obviously I don't agree with
that, but I want to respond because I
think it's a it's a serious question
that needs to be um uh addressed. The
way we might kind of reframe it is is I
think to ask like, okay, is this mental
health crisis the result of someone
being, you know, gay or trans or so on?
Um, or is it the result of communities
and churches and families
that have rejected and ostracized and
isolated and abused? I think that's the
question. And um if you go to the Trevor
Project website, there's a lot. I didn't
want to keep going with all of the
statistics, you know, and give you all
30 minutes of depressing statistics. Um
but I just there's plenty that shows um
it's for sure the latter. Uh in fact,
here was one quote. So LGBTQ youth who
experienced anti-LGBTQ victimization, so
including being physically threatened or
harmed, discriminated against, subjected
to conversion therapy, they reported
more than twice the rate of attempting
suicide in the past year compared to
those who did not have any of these
anti-LGBTQ experiences. And then I'll
close with this. Um these are last
statistics. um the suicide attempt rate.
I found this fascinating where um it was
suicide attempt rate but differing it
out or segmenting it based on the levels
of acceptance. How that person described
their community.
For those who said, "My community is
very unaccepting,"
they had a 21%
suicide attempt rate. For those who
said, "Well, my community is somewhat
unaccepting,"
it dropped to 17. Those who said, "My
community is somewhat accepting,"
it was 13%. Those who said, "My
community is very accepting," dropped to
eight. Those who said, "My family is
very accepting," dropped to six. Can you
see the the trajectory? like what's the
what's the thing here?
Um I I actually draw I know this could
just be I mean I can feel the room. It's
like we're feeling it, you know. Um
but I think this is like the if there's
any kernel of like good news or
something beautiful to pull out of this,
it's that we have such a tremendous
opportunity
to love and welcome and and to literally
be the hands and feet and mouthpieces of
Jesus Christ like and and if you are in
a family like you're a mom, a dad, a
grandma, a grandpa, an aunt, uncle, you
know, and so on like oh my goodness
like the opportunity you have to make a
difference is incredible.
And while um even thinking just kind of
like church community, the Trevor
Project, they didn't give any stats on
like the role of, you know, religious
communities and how accepting versus
unaccepting that, you know, plays out.
Um what's your hunch about how that
plays out? Um like on the positive
sense, what's your hunch about the
powerful beautiful impact that could
have? I mean, as we talk all the time
here, um how we image God, right? By
that I mean how we imagine God and and
who we believe God is revealed to be and
God's heart towards us. And this is true
for all of us, by the way. Um, but no
doubt someone struggling with like
suicidal ideiation. I mean, how we
imagine what God thinks of us.
Oh, does that not go right to the core
of who we are? And it how does it come
out? It comes out in sermons, in songs,
you know, come be loved.
I mean, come behold, come be right like
those that those words, what do they do?
They get into you.
They get into you. Back to that
subconscious. They just they just get in
there and they and they what do they do?
I mean we're talking like they sway
people
because this is the beautiful
opportunity
um is that as we move towards a more
welcoming hospitable um stance like we
are talking about the chance to reverse
suicidal ideiation perhaps not all at
once right I'm not saying like you come
to this church and next week all of your
negativity will be gone in the name of
Jesus you know okay it's a journey for
all of us um but we're talking about a a
change, a drifting away, um major
depressive episodes, major anxiety, a
sense of rejection, a sense of lossness,
a sense that I'm just not loved. I'm
just not accepted. I can't even accept
myself. Like, we're talking about the
chance to begin to shift that by God's
grace. I remember we were at um
Centerpiece in November. Some of you
were at this conference. It's um
centerpiece is an organization that is
basically trying to bridge the gap
between LGBTQ folks and the church and
um the the highlight of the weekend for
me. One I mean there was so many um for
example we had like our worship team
like did music and it was awesome. Um
but the one of the speakers had this
moment his name was Jeff Chu I'll never
forget he's looking at this like ocean
of like five six hundred people. He
turned out to be such a poet. I mean it
was a beautiful talk like completely
like he was not trying to do the
energetic conference speaker thing at
all but he was like just pure
authenticity and I mean it was powerful
but he had this one moment where he just
looked out at everyone and of course
probably 90% as LGBTQ folks and some
allies but like you know we're the we
are the minority. Um and he looked out
at this ocean of humanity and he he
asked this question. He said, "Do you
know, y'all remember this for those of
you who are there? Do you know in your
heart of hearts
that you are loved?"
And he just kept repeating it over and
over. Do you know
in your heart of hearts that you are
loved? My my favorite phrase in that is
actually not you are loved, although
that is very important in the phrase.
It's heart of hearts because it's almost
like that that moment like you remember
in Goodwill Hunting where Matt Damon
like the Robin Williams character. I
don't even remember their actual names
in the movie. I'll just say their real
names. Um where he's saying it's not
your fault. Some of you if you've seen
the movie and he's like yeah I know I
know I know. You know what I mean? Hey,
it's not your fault. Yeah, I get it. I
get it. I get it. He keeps having to say
it right because it's like you don't get
it. you know, and I think that's the
that was where he was just sort of
getting us like in your heart of hearts.
Um, church,
well, first off, to my LGBTQ friends, I
Oh, I long for you to be on the journey
that you would know
that you would know. And now for all of
us, what an opportunity we have. What a
calling
to be a space where people can learn
exactly that. I mean, it's like it's in
ways we're all just trying to get back
to the innocence of childhood. Jesus
loves me. This I know for the Bible
tells me so. It's like we're spending
our whole lives just trying to like
accept that, you know?
But that's the journey. That's the
journey. That's the call. So, let's do
it. I want to um close out actually with
a prayer. I don't do this every Sunday,
but I want to pray um if you'll bow your
heads, close your eyes. If you are a um
an LGBTQ person, if you want to just
open up your hands right there on your
palms or just um on your lap, palms up,
and just kind of in a posture of
receiving. And if you are here as one of
those grandmas or grandpas or aunts,
uncles, friends, ally, just you just
want to love people, I want you to
extend your hands just straight out kind
of just as a sign of like a just
agreeing with this prayer.
Lord Jesus, we lift up our friends,
your children.
You have seen every wound and every
hurt, every tear shed, every moment of
rejection in heartbreak, in fear. You
have seen all of the bad fruit.
But our prayer right now, Lord Jesus, is
for a breakthrough
in hearts and in minds.
in place of their wounds. May you bring
healing
and a call and a capacity to help
others. May we be a church of wounded
healers in the name of Jesus. In place
of hurt, may you bring hope instead of a
sense of rejection,
a word of acceptance. You are accepted
in the knowledge in your heart of hearts
that you are loved.
We stand alongside our friends. We
celebrate who they are. May today be a
turning point in their life. In the name
of the Father, the Son, and the Holy
Spirit. Amen.
Amen.
God's good, huh? God's good. We need
some of those sometimes we need those
moments, those turning points.
And I I pray that that it was a turning
point for you.
So, as we come to the table of the Lord
tonight, as we take in the body of
Christ in the bread and the blood of
Christ in the wine,
we do so as one body. We do so as a
church community longing for good fruit
both collectively and individually.
We do so as a people longing for
healing. So, may this be a moment of
like true um connection with Jesus for
for you. So, the way um we're going to
take communion um is we'll start with
kind of the front rows and we'll just,
you know, work our way back. Um we
practice what's called an open table.
Meaning, if you're here tonight and you
something in you wants to participate,
you're like, I don't know if I have all
the right theology. Um that's okay. If
something in you wants to connect with
the risen Christ, then you are um
not just like tolerated, you are wanted
and we would love for you to
participate. Having said that, there's
no like stigma. If you're just not in a
place to do that, that's okay, too. Um
the red cups are wine. Um the white is
grape juice. And uh and then finally you
can just partake um at any at any point
whether it's immediately or you can
return to your seat.